[Applause]  ladies and gentlemen while you read the  nominees are waiting in the wings side  the war once you give this shoot another  fitting if you don't nominated for Best  Performance by an actor or chose boy a  in sunny Paul Newman in the hustler  Maximilian Schell in judgment at  Nuremburg Spencer Tracy judgment at  Nuremburg and mr. Stuart Whitman in the  mark and his name is Max million Chet  [Music]  ladies and gentlemen I know this award  honors not only me but also the picture  judgment at Nuremburg my wonderful  director and the great cast and  especially that great old man who was  nominated for the eight times now  Spencer Tracy when I came first to this  country I met a custom man and he was  asking what I was doing here and I said  I'm going to do a film and he said to  make good luck boy and I think that was  very unusual for custom men and I can  tell him now that I had it thank you  very much  [Music]